and if I were to be brutally honest
the only reason I ever been mad at the
transgender Community is because I was
at a club in L.A and danced with one of
these [__] for six songs straight
I had no idea
[Applause]
and then the lights came up and I saw
them knuckles I said oh no
and everybody was laughing at me how the
world stopped
I said why didn't you say anything then
I heard that sultry voice I didn't say
anything Dave Chappelle because I was
having a wonderful time and I wasn't
sure how you'd feel about it I said you
knew how I feel
and she said I'm going home I don't want
any trouble from you I said home it's
only two songs left I mean we might as
well
finish the night
and we ended up having breakfast
together
I was starting a guy about a trans
person we both know and he goes I fully
supported I mean I'll play along I was
like I don't think that's what they're
going
he was mad about the trans swimmer Leah
Thomas who kept winning races he said
this is messed up man there needs to be
an asterisk next to those wins and I
said I call [__] he goes exactly I
said no that you care about women
swimming
I've known you for quite some time I've
never heard you mention it
this outrage Rings insincere and he said
what if I have a daughter and I said you
won't
he said what if I raise a girl it turns
out to be an Olympic swimming champion I
said if you can find someone dumb enough
to let you come inside or
I can pretty much guarantee that kid is
not going to grow up to be a winner okay
he was pissed off he said it could
happen I never wore condoms I said you
never wore condoms and you don't have a
kid
it's too bad your sperm isn't a trans
woman it would know how to swim
now I'm joking about all the other stuff
but they go no no I must he must be no
he must mean that right like like a joke
is a window to the comedian's true Soul
it's just that's just not the case uh
I'll take on any view to make the joke
funniest I'll pretend to be right wing
I'll pretend to be left-wing I pretend
to be clever I pretend to be stupid
whatever makes the joke funnier without
prejudice okay full disclosure in real
life of course I support trans rights I
support all human rights and trans
rights are human rights you know live
your best life use your preferred
pronouns be the gender that you feel
that you are but Meet Me Halfway ladies
lose the [__] that's all I'm saying
[Applause]
which brings us to the trans uh people
uh look Hot Topic in comedy a lot of
people talking about it I personally
I've worked with trans people for 20
years in this business I I I have no
issue with trans people I think it must
be a very hard life and if if you know
if there was a surgery that I could have
for me to stop hating myself I'd [__]
take it
so I get it's not an easy choice right
and then so I've got no problems with
trans people and then I I see all the
Comedians and there's there's Chappelle
and Gervais and they told those jokes
and um everyone got upset there was all
this press right and I have no problem
with trans people but I do like press so
here we go
as I said I like trans people do I know
I like trans people I like anyone who's
got a good story
if we're at a party and you tell me
you've cut your dick off you've caught
my attention
I'll sit and chat to you for a while I
feel like you might have some Tales to
tell
can I empathize completely with a trans
person I try to but I can't really
because I'll never know what it's like
to hate the body I'm living in so oh
hang on I do I
I've never understood this argument I
hated the body I live in that's like 98
of us
98 of us get out of the shower and see
ourselves in the mirror and go oh
but I've never wanted to cut my dick off
and that's a fundamental difference
but I do consider myself a bloke with a
six-pack and I'd like you to see me that
way as well
I like trans people I I often think they
shouldn't stop transitioning
keep going
transition more
you ever see a trans person and think to
yourself
they could do with more
let me explain
so when a man becomes a woman and I will
call you a woman or them they her
whatever you want to be called I got all
day I don't give a [__]
all right I'll call you whatever you
want I I regard you as a woman you have
made the decision to change
my regard you as a woman so the surgery
they have to do this right the first
thing they do is they take the hormones
it lowers the bone density raises the
voice a little bit then they go get the
surgery so the first thing they do is
they cut the dick off
and they put that on a plate
I don't I for the life of me I don't
know why people laugh when I say you put
that on a plate
what did you want me to do in this
scenario
they cut the dick off and they Chuck it
of course there's a [__] plate
so they cut the dick off
now they have to make a hole
so they get a spoon
and uh at this stage I should mention
that I'm not a doctor
no formal medical training to speak of
this I just know this happens so
they shovel a hole
but that's just a hole that's not
realistic
you need flaps
and that's where the dick meat comes
into play
so they
they julienne some dick strips
and they get some 3M double-sided tape
and they put two on this side
and one on that side
because I don't know a lot about [__]
but I know they're not symmetrical
so then they made it right that's that's
all really that's good now it's good
so then they grow the hair long they
make sure they're clean shaven right
then they get the fake tits now here is
my problem where they don't transition
enough
they always get perfect tits
believe me
and that's not the real female
experience
they want to be a real woman they got to
get one titty slightly bigger than the
other
and a nipple covering one for no reason
you do that you can play any sport you
want I reckon
[__] are just taking it too far
I don't know why or how everybody got
this goddamn sensitive you know who
hates me the most the transgender
community
yeah oh yeah these [__] I mean
I didn't realize how bad it was these
[__] I was really mad about
that last Netflix special
it's tough man I don't know what to do
about it because because I like them
always have never had a problem with
them
you know
just [__] around
as a matter of fact I think I make fun
of everybody and
I mean as a group of people they have to
admit
it's kind of [__] hilarious man I'm
sorry
[Applause]
I'm sorry not have a sense of humor
about it
they're born feeling like there's
something other than they're born as and
that's
kind of funny you know like
it's funny if it's not happening to you
it's like that white black [__] that's
in the news all the time
Rachel Dozer
he's a white woman but then she dressed
up like a [__]
shot her way up to the very top of
Blackness
and I always wanted to meet her just so
I could understand
I just wanted to like have dinner with
her so I could just look in her eyes
and call her a [__] to her face
[Applause]
the [__] is that [__] talking about I
identify black that is trans talk lady
stop biting stop biting
there's a big difference between her and
a trans the difference between her and
the trans is I believe transgenders I
don't understand them either but I know
they mean what they say
them [__] cut their dicks off
that's all the proof I need
I've never seen somebody just throw
their dick away don't need it
I don't understand but I believe you
when I support your decision
[__]
as far as Rachel willing to go hmm
what is Rachel willing to do so that we
blacks can believe that she believes
she's actually one of us
[__] are you willing to put a lien on
your house invest in a mixtape that
probably won't work out
[Applause]
she didn't even change her name
didn't even change her name her name is
Rachel I can't believe in that name
you want my support you're gonna have to
change your name to the blackest [__]
I've ever heard
but you're gonna have to change your
name to Draymond Green
[Applause]
your name than that
that [__] is black on paper
if you take Draymond Green in the Airbnb
that [__] will log off automatically
[Applause]
an independent study released this week
confirms that President Clinton has
appointed more minorities to high-level
government posts than any other
president for purposes of the study
women were counted as minorities and
attorney general Janet Reno was counted
as a woman
cannot make jokes about trans people
it's what they're going through is so
incomparable and you can't imagine how
hard their life is and the [__] that
they have to go through therefore you
cannot make jokes about trans people and
and I I hear you I hear you loud and
clear
but
the point that you're trying to make is
you're saying I can't make jokes about
somebody because of how hard their life
is and you are making very valid points
in that I don't know how hard that life
is I imagine it is tremendously harder
than my life I can't imagine how hard
that is to go through and I wish you the
best of luck boys
at the same time to retort that argument
you also don't have
the hardest life you know who has life
way harder than trans people that we
never talk about
in Paris
think about comparatively people in
wheelchairs have a much harder life do
they complain about it no we gave them a
couple of ramps and kept it pushing we
[__] it
look somebody some people are gonna
think this is an insensitive comparison
I think it's a step in the right
direction personally I think I think if
we want to head towards trans equality
we [__] start with better parking you
know it's it's the least we could do
it's the least we could do I don't know
where we'd put them we can't assign them
anything
look if you're still upset about the
comparison
feel free to think about it and tell me
I'm wrong
let's say you did let's let's say you
took somebody with with no legs
and a trans person
and you put them in the same room the
same handicap accessible room
see who you think has the harder life
I just I feel like I'm trapped inside of
another person's body
so you have four legs
um
you're you're not listening it's not
about that it's a sometimes my mental
health will take such a toll that I
could just
I could just jump off of my balcony
jump
what's that
you're you're not here people will call
me the wrong pronouns
someone called me Chariot Tubman the
other day
I think a pronouns the worst thing you
can be called
come on
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh you mean transportation
[Music]
[Applause]
meanwhile with President Clinton's
second inaugural approaching attention
has turned to what the women will be
wearing at the festivities according to
the White House first lady Hillary
Rodham Clinton will wear a gown by Oscar
de la Renta Tipper Gore will appear in a
Jennifer George Ensemble and attorney
general Janet Reno will be outfitted by
Rochester Big and Tall
yeah
what's the beef look it's weird to hate
someone because they're trans right but
it's also weird to love someone because
they're trans shouldn't you like them
based on who they are as a person
content of the character people are so
phony I love Caitlyn Jenner why she
sucks
she's against gay marriage ran over a
person what's the good part
then they go well they have hard lives
all right we'll soda midgets
why don't you talk about how much you
like them where's that hashtag I don't
see any tweets about midgets who's kind
of hard on a minute hard to get around
hard to drive hard to get work no love
and look I'm not anti-trans but I am
pro-mage
when I say the genders I am only
speaking of two of the several hundred
that now exist
I would like it to be clear where I
stand I have no problem calling anybody
anything they wish to be called it is no
burden on me you can identify as a
shoelace if you want to and I will call
you Zippity zimzer if you ask me to
do I think it's a little silly yeah but
so is badminton and that's an Olympic
event you know so
let's talk about these [__] all
right uh
people say it's like this hateful word
I don't know why it's hateful I think
it's just short
transgender
[__]
Graham mother
granny
welcome to the English language [__]
short and [__] and Attaway my name's
Andrew my nickname would be
triggered guys
very problematic the way you shrunk my
[__] down and out of the Y like we do
with [__] everything
string
Australian
it's what we do
you have a friend who's like El
Salvadorian you're like Mexican I'm not
[Applause]
a whole [__] country every
two Javier are you kidding there's 15
syllables in your goddamn country
shorten the [__] country
pyramids Tacos Mexico that's what we're
doing wrap it up
I know what some of you are thinking
like what if you called someone Blackie
obviously that would be hateful you made
it longer
I thought this through [__]
but don't worry
[__] will be accepted
everybody's so concerned about them they
will be accepted I promise you just like
everyone else
when they're attractive
Welcome to the Real World okay if you're
ugly it [__] sucks I wouldn't know
some of you
all I'm saying is Caitlyn got a lot of
Bruce left you know as
I ain't get all the Bruce out some Bruce
left in there
Caitlyn could transition back with a wet
wipe
[Applause]
yeah
in Northern Florida refuse from a paper
mill has caused female fish to develop
male sex organs and in her related story
attorney general Janet Reno
[Applause]
okay
I don't know if if I'll ever transition
I don't know
I like to keep my options open
but if I do I got my name picked out
I already got my name this will be my
name if if if I ever transition my name
will be Rue
because it's like a Drew but without the
D and
[Applause]
and the interest of pronouns here's
here's mine I identify as a laugh
because I am a man who stutters
him
also this week in Washington several
prominent Democrats joined Republicans
in pleading with attorney general Janet
Reno to investigate fundraising abuses
and also to shave
[Music]
you know you hear all those letters
together all the time lbgt lbgt and you
think it's just one big movement it's
not
all those letters are their own movement
they're just travel in the same car
together
so the jeans are just driving the car
of course next to the G's and the
passenger seat
is the elves
everybody likes the L's
except for the G's
okay
I don't know what that's about I just
know the G's don't like them that much
the G's always say like little
subliminal digs on them it's unnecessary
[__] it's not mean but you know what I
mean they just be like
oh he wouldn't wear that
the only thing that breaks the tension
between the L's and G's
are the bees in the back seat
that's right there you go everybody
scream out when you hear your letter
[Applause]
if it's one thing that the L's and the
G's agree on is that the bees are
[__] gross
they seem greedy to the L's and the G's
you know what I mean this is sitting in
the backseat like yeah man I'll [__]
anybody in this car what's going on man
[Applause]
[Music]
and sitting next to the bees all the way
in the back seat by themselves looking
out the window
that's the tease
everybody in the car respects the tease
but everyone also presents the tease
it's not the t's fault but everyone in
the car just feels like the t's are
making the trip take longer
anything the T say gets on everybody's
nerves and then the teams don't even say
anything bad they should be in the back
talking to himself
I'm hot shut up shut the [__] out okay
just roll the window down you
[__] I don't know what you
what
could you pull over at the next exit I
need to use the restroom
there is not a restroom for you for four
states [__]
so we can get
[Applause]
what
and just when that car can't get any
more intense the queues are hitchhiking
that they pick up on the road some white
dude and booty shorts just walking down
the freeway
[Applause]
geez see him that guy might be one of us
hey are you okay you need some help and
he come over there with them booty
shorts leaning on the window
hey what's going on fellas
lady
whatever pronoun makes you feel
comfortable in the back
yeah
I don't really know where I'm going
I don't know if I'm gay or I'm straight
or whatever
all I know for sure is that um getting
this car
and they make him get in and sitting
between the bees and the t's
I feel bad for tease
but they're so confusing
and it's not all my fault I feel like
they need to take some responsibility
for my jokes
because I didn't come up with this idea
on my own
this idea that a person can be born in
the wrong body
but they have to admit that's [__]
hilarious predicament
it's really [__] funny
if it happened to me you'd laugh
wouldn't you
that wouldn't be funny if it happened to
me
I think it would be what if what if it
did what if I was what if I was Chinese
but but born in this [__] body that's
not funny
and for the rest of my life I had to go
around making that face hey everybody
I'm Chinese
and everyone get mad stop making that
face that's offensive what
this is how I feel inside
transgender athletes I don't [__]
understand that you know I understand it
you know you want to switch around I
don't give a [__] but I'm a sports fan
that's a really New Concept to me that
you can be a dude right ranked 80th in
the [__] world you have your dick cut
off you put on a sports bra and now
you're the number one tennis player in
the world just coming out there with
your man's shoulders
that doesn't seem fair I might be wrong
I might just be an old guy I have no
idea
but I'm hearing rumors like some of them
are getting into that MMA you can't have
that [__]
am I nuts that is a [__] dude
beating the [__] out of a woman
Jesus Christ he might as well hit her
with this discarded dick like a
flashlight
[Applause]
Salvage grounded her grounded pound is
incredible
meanwhile FBI director Louie free said
this week that attorney general Janet
Reno might have a conflict of interest
in her investigation of democratic
fundraising free also pointed out that
Reno might have a conflict of interest
between her X and Y chromosome
foreign
very fluid now you never know what
you're going to get you know my friend
hooked up with a with a really beautiful
woman they were fooling around the Dick
came out yeah my friend went nuts yeah
it's crazy lost his mind I've never uh
never had that happen to be close I ever
got to that was one time I bit into a
chocolate chip cookie turned out to be
an oatmeal raisin
looked just like the real thing and I
wasn't ready for the nuts
much like my friend I figured out it's
already in my mouth I might as well
finish it off
everything's a touchy issue now isn't it
like they're doing a trans superhero in
a Marvel movie that's a big story yeah
they're doing a trans and you know
they're just patting themselves on the
back like we did it guys
we did it
you know they're gonna mess it up
they're so politically correct in those
movies there's going to be a super
villain like you mutants are all freaks
except for you you're brave
the rest of you ah attorney general
Janet Reno said this week that she is
fed up with Republicans complaining to
the press that she has not named an
independent Council to investigate
President Clinton's fundraising said
Reno quote if these people don't like
the way I'm doing my job let them come
talk to me man to man all right
no women I I mean the old-fashioned ones
you know the old-fashioned women oh God
you know the ones with wombs
oh those [__] dinosaurs
no I love the the new women I know the
new women they're great aren't they you
know the new ones we've been seeing
lately they were the ones with beards
and [__] they're as good as
they're as good as gold I love them
no it's the old fashioned and now the
old-fashioned they were like oh they
want to use a lot of toilets why
shouldn't they use your toilets for
ladies they are ladies look at their
pronouns
what about this person isn't a lady well
his penis
penis you [__] bigot
what if he rapes me what if she raped
you
you [__] Turf [__]
attorney general Janet Reno has
assembled a task force to determine
whether Federal campaign Finance laws
were violated by democrats Republicans
or both another task force will attempt
to determine whether attorney general
Reno is a man a woman or both
I am not saying that to say that trans
women aren't women
I am just saying that those [__] that
they got
you know what I mean
I'm not saying it's not [__] but that's
like
Beyond [__] or impossible [__]
tastes like [__] that's not quite what
it is is it
it's not blood that's beet juice
[Applause]
what happened to those transgender
bathrooms you guys remember that was a
big issue
of every bathroom needs to be gender
neutral
neutral and I will like
I don't care anymore
that's a lot to change for a very small
percentage of the population
like trans people are 0.1 of the
population
representative population
also has six fingers
does that mean we're gonna go all right
no more Bloods forget it really close
plus I'm not inclusive at all
from now on it's fitting Zone
you'll only have things where all hands
are comfortable
and no more high fives we're getting rid
of hot dogs
that's my hands we're doing High hands
just use whatever [__] bathroom you
want let's
go into the bathroom after the shortest
line between open
and then when the first
or gender walks in we go
why every bathroom is transgender when
you gotta be better
thank you